ein park aus kulturen zehn meter unter
dem meeresspiegel
kunst entsteht ein wandel durch die
kraft des ozeans vereinnahmt von seinem
meeresbewohnern
erschaffen wurden die skulpturen von ihm
den britischen künstler jason terry
taylor in fast allen meeren der welt hat
der studierte bildhauer seine kunstwerke
schon installiert
ich wollte mit diesem ganz neuen raum
experimentieren hat mit seinen neuen
herausforderungen
es war sehr spannend weil ich
festzustellen begann das sich mit der
installation der figuren nicht nur kunst
erschaffen sondern auch einen lebensraum
für marines leben und eine ganz
praktische lösung für umweltprobleme
derzeit lebt der künstler auf der
kanaren insel lanzarote hier und sein
atelier arbeitet er zusammen mit seinen
mitarbeitern an neun skulpturen am
anfang steht immer ein gipsabdruck meist
von menschen aus der jeweiligen region
ihr seht es trocknet sofort wir müssen
also sehr schnell sein zum einen weil es
für das modell nicht so angenehm ist und
weil der gips so schnell aushärtet
nach 20 minuten ist der gipsabdruck
fertig verdient im zweiten schritt als
vorlage für die skulpturen
wir produzieren die skulpturen aus
zement
es ist ein spezieller zement der ph
neutral und für den unterwasser gebrauch
gemacht ist zusatzstoffe machen ihn viel
stärker als normalen fische und korallen
siedeln sich gern auf ihn an und er hat
eine lebensspanne von mehreren hundert
jahren das richtige material ist
wirklich wichtig sind die skulpturen
fertig werden sie zu wasser gelassen
wie hier in mexiko 2009 mit mehr als 500
einzelfiguren entstand eine der größten
unterwasser kunst attraktionen der welt
heute fast sechs jahre später sind die
skulpturen mit korallen überwucherten
lebensraum für fische und dazwischen ein
attraktives ausflugsziel für taucher ein
künstliches riff mit dem der künstler
auch zum naturschutz beitragen will
die installationen locken die touristen
weg von den natürlichen korallenriffen
so können sie die echten rewe nicht mehr
beschädigen
die parks sind also sehr gut und
touristen aktivitäten zu kontrollieren
und dazu kommt dass meine arbeiten
gewissermaßen personen in interaktion
mit den meeresbewohnern porträtieren
also ist der mensch ausnahmsweise mal
nützlich für den planeten stadt endlich
skulpturen die auch zum nachdenken
anregen sollen für dieses versunkener
auf kritik an den auswüchsen der
modernen gesellschaft gespickt mit
ironie
auch das ist teil seiner kunst das
jüngste projekt steht vor den bahamas 60
tonnen schwerer applus figur auf den
schultern trägt die welt über wasser in
diesem jahr geht es nun nach europa in
dieser woche soll jason kerr ist ehlers
erstes europäisches unter wasser aus
herum entstehen zirka zehn meter unter
dem meeresspiegel hat der künstler mit
seinem team den perfekten ort ausfindig
gemacht wir haben sehr lange nach der
richtigen stelle gesucht
die strukturen müssen natürlich von
starken winden strömungen und wellen
geschützt und das hier ist die
geschützte stelle der ganzen insel
der meiste wind kommt von dort der
meeresboden dort ist sehr flach so ist
es ja einfach für taucher die strukturen
dann noch ausfindig zu machen
einige dutzend skulpturen für den
unterwasser park sind schon fertig mehr
als 300 sollen es noch werden
im sommer will jason kerr ist taylor mit
seinem team damit beginnen sie nach und
nach im atlantik zu platzieren 2016 soll
die ungewöhnliche ausstellung fertig
werden hier gibt es ein ganz anderes
klima im vergleich zu den orten wo ich
vorher gearbeitet habe zum beispiel der
karibik im atlantik ist dass kinder das
wasser ist blauer es gibt ein ganz
anderes ökosystem und ich bin gespannt
darauf wie sich die skulpturen hier mit
der zeit verändern werden wie ihre züge
dann irgendwann aussehen vielleicht ein
wenig furchteinflößend wie bei diesen
skulpturen oder auch irgendwie
verwunschen eines ist jedoch sicher die
kunst von jazz dickeres taylor wird bei
jedem besuch immer wenn wenig anders
aussehen